hey david if joe biden manages to win
florida back from trump is it over
for donald trump so i understand why
people are asking this florida is a big
prize electorally it's 29 electoral
votes
and right now joe biden is leading by an
average of 6.4
in florida uh that's a range of anywhere
from
being tied in florida to biden plus 10
in florida
the real clear politics average in
florida right now is that biden is up by
6.4 so let's start with just the simple
mathematical case if you start with the
2016 map where trump won florida
and the only change you make is you flip
florida to biden
that is not enough for joe biden to win
the presidency biden
winning florida and otherwise the map
staying as 27 2016
would give trump 277 still you only need
270 to be president so
florida alone will not help joe biden
win
however these elections
rarely are completely isolated where
everything is the same as 2016 except
one state
flips if biden wins florida he probably
is going to win
something else like for example
wisconsin
michigan or pennsylvania if biden
wins florida back and wisconsin he wins
if biden wins florida back and michigan
he wins if biden wins florida and
pennsylvania back
he also wins and even if trump holds
florida so
trump keeps florida and keeps ohio biden
can still win by winning any two
of the three states wisconsin michigan
and pennsylvania
now of course there's other
opportunities for joe biden as well
arizona is very much in play for joe
biden
north carolina is close so in the
mathematical sense alone
florida only will not do it for joe
biden
my belief is that if we see joe biden
win in florida
he will certainly win some other state
that i mentioned
there's almost an exact analysis to be
made in ohio
the difference is ohio's only 18
electoral votes
whereas florida is 29 so if biden
flips ohio but not florida
he still likely needs ohio plus two
unless it's a very high population state
with more electoral votes
now in the end we've got 50 elections
we can't control anything other than our
one vote and we have to make sure to use
it so when i look at these scenarios you
know every once in a while i will look
at
270 to win.com is a great place where
you can start with the 2016 map
and say okay we start with 2016 and flip
this or flip that
there's a bunch of different scenarios
that have biden winning
there's one scenario that has a tie i
believe it's 269 269
and a bunch of scenarios that have trump
winning all i can do is vote
and so when i cast my ballot via
absentee which i've already requested in
the state of massachusetts
i will be doing it with the belief that
this state could come down to my vote it
is mathematically unlikely to be that
way
but every single one of us should say
would i vote
if my vote could be the difference maker
of course your vote could be the
difference maker meaning yes you should
vote and we all need to make sure that
we do